from mcdonald's milkshakes
to nando's chicken
to supermarket shelves
customers going without because of
delivery problems and now that includes
patients waiting for their flu vaccine
there aren't enough hgv drivers to get
jabs to gps
it's extremely frustrating i mean this
puts a huge pressure on hard working
practices we've been planning our autumn
flu campaign to start at the beginning
of september and then with just a
moment's notice
told that the flu vaccine won't be
delivered to practices
the uk's largest provider of flu
vaccines says there will be delays of up
to two weeks
the longer jabs remain here the more
chance they won't make it into patients
arms the flu vaccination program in a
normal year is meticulously planned but
this year a record 35 million people are
eligible for a jab it was hoped it would
stop the nhs being overwhelmed with flu
and covert 19 cases
the hauliers say these problems are no
surprise thanks to politics and the
pandemic it's the perfect storm we had
the kobe last year which resulted in 40
000 hgv driving tests not being
undertaken
then we had of course the wonderful
brexit
which resulted in an awful lot of
particularly eastern block drivers
returning to their native lands
and they've not come back since labour
are calling for visas to bring back
foreign workers the government needs to
absolutely get a grip on this crisis
what it hasn't been doing is
coordinating a response to this and it's
just pretty shocking that 18 months
after the government already was warned
and parliamentary questions were being
asked about the shortage of heavy goods
vehicles drivers that that shortage has
now
almost doubled the department of health
said there are enough jabs adding the
delivery from one supplier is delayed by
one or two weeks and this should have no
impact on the flu vaccination program
overall
but doctors are warning of a crisis if
practices have to wait much longer to
reschedule appointments
uptake of the flu jab soared last winter
but this year's rollout is facing a
logistical nightmare becky cottrell sky
news liverpool